you were my love island experience
and i wouldn't want it any other way i'm
regretful for
the way that i spent the past few days
in not being true to how i felt deep
down it took me until today
to tell you
i wish i could have spent more time with
you i wish i could have finished this
with you but
just wasn't in the cards for us you and
connor had a three film saga that played
out on screen i mean so much was packed
into this time on on love island
so how let's break it down how hard was
it to be
in the villa with connor especially
after you and jalen had
called it off it was extremely difficult
to be in there
with connor even when jalen and i were
at our best
i think jalen was more of almost like a
distraction for me
i think that i kind of associated him
with the feeling of casa amor when
i was free and i was having fun but the
moment conor came back
it like it was very hard to see him um i
missed him a lot and
once he was you know pursuing things
with moira it was even harder
and i think that's why i was kind of
ready to leave because i realized
i really couldn't be in there and not be
with him it was it was too hard for me
personally
yeah i want to know your thoughts on the
the connor moira
recoupling because it was almost like it
came off like you felt
betrayed by them and maybe thought conor
was gonna pick you or you guys were
gonna have a second go at things
how did you feel about it yeah so i
think the reason
why i did feel you know some feelings of
like
i know betrayal is a strong word and and
i know that i said that
and it did feel that way in some regards
only because
conor and moira were not close at any
point in the show
especially you know prior to casa moore
um and i had become like best friends of
moira like that was
my girl and then conor was obviously my
guy
and they were very much never
each other's people so i think i kind of
felt like
of all the people in the villa you know
of all the people you go for
the fact that they would you know know
how i felt about both of them
and then move forward it was a tough
pill to swallow but i also
knew that it was not my place to stand
in the way of it
um my frustration was that i felt like i
wasn't getting honest answers from moira
or
conor as to what their intentions were
because
all of my conversations with moira were
about a friendship
and like very much a friendship and even
at these thoughts like the night before
the recoupling
the thought of coupling up with conor in
a romantic way made her cringe
like straight up cringe so to then have
it change
so quickly and and find out
through other people and not through
them was very upsetting and i didn't
feel like
moira was able to be honest with me and
all i asked was for honesty
and connor never asked me
he definitely did not need my permission
whatsoever but he never
came to me and said i know that i'm
spending a lot more time with moira
i know that it might be romantic between
us eventually
how do you feel about this are you
feeling okay do you want to talk about
it because
as soon as i came back from casa with
jalen
i tried to check in with connor every
day at least once a day and see how he
was doing
and i just wanted the same respect from
connor and i just kind of felt like
neither of them was really
asking me or telling me what was going
on
and i think that was what i really
struggled with and i really started to
feel isolated because here's the people
i'm the closest to
and i i did feel i did feel like there
wasn't as much consideration for my
feelings your guys conversation was
really interesting because it was like
you guys were talking about it and then
it cuts to her confessional and she was
like almost
annoyed by the conversation like how did
you guys leave things do you guys feel
like you were
on good terms or annoyed oh i had no
idea
yeah i guess you haven't seen it yet but
it was like you guys you were talking
about
them coupling up and saying i'm gonna
kind of keep my distance from connor
today
and then it cuts to her like
confessional or whatever and she's like
you know we're not the she's not the
only one with an x in here it's kind of
selfish kind of reaction
i don't know if mackenzie is thinking as
clearly as the rest of us
i think a lot of us have ex-couplings in
here
and are handling it just fine
but i think you know mackenzie might be
making a little bit bigger of a deal
about it
and i think it's a little selfish i
think that the only
person who could relate to how i felt
about conor being my
ex is selly with johnny if they were to
ever break up
the level of where connor and i were at
versus the other couples
the only comparable couple is johnny and
sally maybe later on another couple
could be at that level
but i also would never ever go for
calvin
and you know that's the thing and my
point of what i was trying to say to her
was with moira was i wanted to salvage
our friendship
because that was a priority for me but i
felt like if i wasn't honest about how i
was feeling
then it would be impossible to do that
and so
everybody realized apparently other than
moira that conor's recoupling speech
sounded like it was about me and most of
the guys admitted later they thought
that he was about to pick me
and that was why i was so hurt by it was
it was things that were specifically
sounding like us and i communicated that
to moira and i said that's why i need to
keep my distance because this is feeling
too personal
and i think that you guys haven't really
been honest about where this is going
and she didn't express any kind of
annoyance with me
nothing whatsoever so that is surprising
to me to hear
and clearly she was not being honest
with me about it because
i mean the night before the recoupling
she said i hope that you boys come in
and i said why
and she said because we can meet new
boys
i feel like you were operating like the
real world
where everyone else was like in game
mode or something like you were
operating like a real person
i do feel like for me there were there
were elements
of this process that i know were
supposed to like just give into the
process but for me
whether it's real world or villa world
i was never going to go for someone's ex
that i was that close to
right and i really felt like moira nice
friendship was on another level
that it was kind of one of those things
where
if they did have these romantic feelings
i was going to be supportive
but it was the dishonesty and the
talking behind my back about it
and but that is something that i
struggle with the whole time i was on
the show
was i did feel like everything i would
say behind someone's back i would then
say to their face
and that was why i did have awkward
conversations like that one with moira
because i'm like i'm not going to keep
telling everybody else in the villa
that i'm mad at conor for his speech and
he knew he had thought about picking me
i'm not going to just keep talking about
other people and not tell moira
and that was what i did and you know if
she had
if she had side conversations or was
talking about it that i didn't know then
i mean i keep it real like i tell
everybody i i don't have like a
a hidden agenda i don't talk about
things behind people's back that's just
not my style
i mean at the end there like you and
connor had this really tearful
conversation
do you regret anything about how things
played out with connor
is there anything you wish you said to
him that you didn't say
well i don't know how much they included
on the show
of conor nice conversation upstairs on
the balcony
but it was a very overdue conversation
about
everything that had happened everything
we were feeling because
i had heard from justine that connor
still had feelings for me
but connor every time i spoke to him was
trying to play it cool
and like never expressed to me any kind
of sadness about our breakup or anything
and so that was the first time that we
both admitted to each other like we
still have feelings for each other we
miss each other
we've we had to go through
self-growth before we both realized we
needed to grow more as individuals
before we could work as a couple
because i do think that there are
elements of our relationship that were
amazing
and i do think that in the real world we
could have a great relationship
i just feel like so much of this
experience is about
preparing yourself as a person to
receive
love and be ready for love and i feel
like as individuals
in the villa we were not ready for that
level of relationship
do you think you know if connor and
moira are just
friendship couple he comes out single or
whatever like do you guys think there's
potential there
after the island i definitely think if
conor comes out single then i would love
you know to get his phone number and to
talk and to
really see if this is if we have a real
shot at this at least
at least i just miss my best friend like
it was so hard
obviously you see how amazing connor is
and
i was never blind to that i knew how
lucky i was
and that was why when we were having
problems and i felt like
maybe we aren't what's best for each
other it was really difficult because
i know i'm never going to meet another
guy like connor i know he
is truly like the sweetest person and
that is why it was so difficult for me
and i don't
i don't show my emotions always on my
face a lot of times when i'm truly hurt
by something
you won't see it on my face i very much
try to hide it
and it's really the times where i'm
not as upset that i'm like more vocal
and maybe i cry about it and it's just
i'm weird the way i express myself
sometimes but you know obviously before
i left
he said he told me i love you for the
first time
and he had never said that to me before
and he said in front of everybody
and then he said it again when we were
speaking privately and i know he had a
lot of regret
because he had wanted he had considered
recoupling with me
and i think that he did feel responsible
for me leaving
and i i think he just didn't realize
that our time was so limited
and um i know that he did have some
regrets and
he voiced to me that he wanted to see me
on the outside and you know give this a
shot
but i very much um understand that
he's got to continue his journey in
there and i think he's got to carry it
through
whether that's with moyer as a
friendship whether it's more than a
friendship
whether it's someone new i don't know
but i respect that
i feel like i had my journey and it was
done i felt like it was done
i felt ready to go and i know that his
isn't over yet so um
do i hope he'll come out single yeah but
i also just want what's best for him and
whatever makes him happy honestly
we watch so much growth between you like
connor really pissed me off when he went
on that date with lauren and then came
back and was like i want to be
like i actually don't want to be your
boyfriend anymore and like he didn't
communicate and i was like why are you
acting like this
and then when you came back with jalen i
was like mckenzie what are you doing
and now i'm just like they're now
they're it's coming full circle like
they can find their way back to each
other they've both grown they're ready
yeah
i definitely feel that way i think that
like i said i think
love island like you're you're in there
looking for love
but the greatest takeaway is self-love
because if you don't have that level of
self love the confidence the
the care for yourself like prioritizing
yourself and what you need and what's
best for you
then this process will wreck you and it
will destroy you
because it is so up and down it's
emotional
it's raw it's real and i just feel like
if connor and i reach a point where we
feel very good with ourselves and where
we're at in our lives
i think that you know sky's the limit i
think we could work out and i am i am
hopeful
but i also think that if we just have an
amazing friendship
like that would be incredible too so
well i want to talk about jalen really
quick because you
re-coupled with him and listen
yeah i was gonna say do you regret that
absolutely
so he he pissed me off okay so he
comes gets into the villa he's with you
he was like all in with you and then it
was like as soon as he knew he was in
he pulled the switch and was like oh i'm
into kirsten i kind of want to pull back
and
he was playing yeah i was vulnerable
he knew that for me like going into casa
moore
i was in such a a state of mind
because i had all these ups and downs of
conor
and the house at that point had very
much the boys had made me feel like i
was the villain
and connor was this innocent person to
be protected
and so i felt like i was walking on
eggshells in the villa
and so when the boys left the reason why
you see me being so comfortable
so free is because these boys while they
had their opinions about what they saw
on tv
they gave me like a real shot and they
gave me a chance to just be myself
and i think that i had expressed you
know
no one has tried to go for me other than
conor and i'm like
it's weird in the outside world i'm used
to being hit on but in here it's like
there's guys coming in all the time but
they know i'm unavailable
and i think that jalen saw me as an easy
target
and i think that he saw like you know
what if i
can get her to like me and like trust me
then i'll get a spot in the villa and i
genuinely believe he was playing a game
and
i don't think i'm wrong about that still
so and i felt like he was completely
influenced by
what he saw on tv versus what the guys
were putting into his head i don't know
i just i don't even know what happened
there i think that he wanted a spot in
the house and i think that he liked me
well enough
but the thing is we noticed like he said
to moira that he was all in on her
so into her he says then when he comes
to me he's talking
he's talking about the on moira and i'm
trying to defend moira
and i'm i even encouraged him talk to
moira talk to kirsten like these are my
girls they're great go talk to them he's
like no no
i'm only into you i'm only into you i'm
all in on you and then
he goes in um and then he comes in the
house
and he's immediately acting different
and i think the moment he saw
the way like because i wasn't that
popular with the boys at the time
i think he was like well you know what i
might get eliminated if i stay coupled
up with kinsey so i'm gonna ditch her
and i'm gonna go for someone else and so
he went from calling us the power couple
one day
to speaking in the kitchen at me in a
very disrespectful manner
to the point where then i go outside and
sleep on a couch outside rather than
being in a bed with him
yeah and it tries to paint it like i was
the bad guy in the situation
taking advantage of the fact that the
guys in the house
didn't really have the best opinion of
me based on
their own assumptions of what was
happening and then he
went for share and you know i'm just
like it's so obviously a game
and i did feel very used and it was
upsetting because
i really think i should have just come
back from casa more single
and still told conor i think we need
space but i think we should be single
and conor was like i wish you had done
that and i i think i just thought
that if i came back single i would be so
easy to slide back into old habits of
conor
and i wouldn't really take that space
that i needed
and um you know it is probably my only
regret in the villa honestly was
bringing jalen back to
back from the casa experience seeing
connor walk out
holding your teddy bear was so
soul-crushing
i mean what was going through your mind
in that moment
so this was something i don't know if it
was included on the show but something
that i frequently talked about after i
had sent
gus because my every intention was to be
winning for connor
when he came back and that was why i
sent us
because honestly at the beginning of
casa i thought conor might come back
with another girl
like that was what i was thinking was
going to happen and i was like i'll be
waiting here he'll know because i sent
gus
once i realized that maybe it wasn't the
best thing for us to be together anymore
and i was starting to have these
questions about it
i was like oh my god though he's going
to come back in with gus
and i just like i had several panic
attacks leading up to it because i'm
like this
i cannot even tell you how much it upset
me that i could not
communicate with conor and explain to
him what was going on and what was
happening
because even though i did not cry
my heart literally broke with gus like
that
i was broken it hurts so badly
oh it's just it was it was too much i'm
curious to get your thoughts on some of
the other couples
um because johnny and sally
uh america's i don't know how they feel
about johnny so
you obviously didn't see what went down
in costa more but you probably heard
about it with the girl
and i talked to her and she and
the other girls in casa moore were like
yeah
johnny was coming on to her pursued her
kind of claimed her
all this stuff and then there's also
johnny's ex on tick tock
saying that he was like kind of
possessive and they were like he'd like
propose to her like right before he came
to the
villa so i'm just i i don't know red
flags about johnny i'm just curious
how you feel johnny i mean there's a
reason why out of
everyone in the house i never wanted to
have a conversation with him
like it was hard on you he was really
hard on you i know he was
and i think it was hard on me because i
think he knew that i saw through him
and i think that i was one of the only
ones that didn't buy
it and that's why i never made an effort
to talk to him
i never made an effort to get to know
him because i just did not buy what he
was selling at all
but i also knew that in that house
there was no one who was on my side
about the johnny situation so i just
didn't i didn't try to bring it up i was
not trying to hurt sally
like i was like this is how this is how
i feel
and i i'm questioning who he is i don't
know who he is as a person but i'm not a
fan of what i've seen
and i knew what he was saying about me
which i thought was so funny because i'm
like
you're the most vocal about my
relationship when you don't know me
and you barely really know connor that
well so
why is why are you the mouthpiece about
this that's
but that was like johnny was very much
in charge of what happened in the villa
and if you weren't on johnny's good side
then you were on the wrong side
so uh protect selly at all costs i hope
you're wrong but
i viewers are getting a lot of red flags
yeah i don't know what his intentions
are with sully
they might be genuine with sally and i
hope they are i i feel like they
probably are
but i as a person johnny and i did not
connect no
i was not a fan oh i was like i know we
just touched on this but i was like so
annoyed that
the guys were so mad at you when you
came back with jalen because
connor did something very similar like
he went on a date with lauren and was
like
yeah i'm interested and then came back
and like broke up with you so i was like
it's not bad he so what he did was he
came he was not he went on the date with
lauren and acted as though he was single
when at the time we were boyfriend and
girlfriend
yeah then admits to me that he had told
everybody that we weren't boyfriend
girlfriend
but then once he gets back proceeds to
then ask me again to be his girlfriend
up on the rooftop it was so
frustrating i was like connor i was on
your side man you blessed me
but that was like that was my dilemma
was and that was when i kind of started
to reach the point where
i was questioning if i was going to be
able to succeed in that house
because conor was getting away with
things that
and i understand why conor did the
things he did
but to give him you know like immunity
or not
or not hold him accountable for what he
did with lauren but then
to crucify me is what i did not
understand
because i very much vocalized to the
girls and to connor
if you had never done what you did with
lauren i would have absolutely
waited for you without a doubt i was
loyal the whole time it was only
once he had put had gone up and down
with how he felt
and i did not know if he was going to
come back single
and so that was why i went about casa
the way that i did
because he had been so inconsistent with
his feelings
i'm like i've been loyal and i've been
i've
you know i've been disappointed before
so i need to do what's best for me
um and the boys weren't i just don't
think we're willing to see that though
like they didn't
and what i also heard was when they were
in casa they kept telling connor
she's gonna come back with a guy so it's
like if you thought that i was going to
come back with someone else and then i
did then why were you so upset if you
literally thought i was going to do that
that's what i i couldn't understand i
think
what i do want to say is like people
don't understand what it's like to be in
that experience
and unfortunately we are there for love
yes but so much of it has to do with the
other people in the house and in these
group
interactions and i was struggling so
much
with how i was dealing with being in
this house with these people
who did not necessarily have my back
like in the guys they were not
supportive
so it was very hard to be my best self
than in my relationship
and i do wish that i could have had more
self-awareness of how i was feeling
about the situation in the house so that
way i could have appreciated conor moore
and i could have communicated better
when i was upset and express more to him
that it was never him it was not what he
was doing because
i think i just assumed that he
knew it wasn't about him and i just wish
that i had
expressed that more to him and i wish
that
i had come back from casa a more single
and just really had an honest
conversation with conor and said look
i don't know if we should be a romantic
couple but i know how much i
care about you and i've fallen for you
and i
love being around you but are are we
what's best for each other i wish that
we had had that conversation that we had
on my last day
i wish we'd had that four days prior but
i think that everything happens for a
reason
and connor and i always talked about
timing
and because we realized that if we
hadn't paired up on the first day
we probably never would have paired up
just because of the way that we are as
people and it was so unexpected that we
ended up together
and so that's why i kind of have faith
that the timing of
how things happen and when i left that
maybe
i needed to leave for us to
reconcile and get back together on the
outside like maybe it had to happen that
way maybe that was the timing of it
um and you know i just wish that
i wish that i could have spent more time
with him there i do but
it is what it is and i had an amazing
experience and i'm really glad that i
got to leave the way that i did and
and not have um not have this like
laundry list of things i wish i had done
you know
[Music]
so